más de 100 millones de refugiados y
desplazados en el mundo es decir el 1
por ciento de la población mundial el
aumento acelerado se produjo
principalmente a causa de la guerra en
ucrania en la medida que más de 14
millones de ucranianos
principalmente mujeres y niños se han
visto obligados a desplazarse 8 millones
lo han hecho dentro de ucrania mientras
que 6 millones han cruzado las fronteras
sin embargo no se pueden dejar de lado
otros conflictos como explicó a france
william spindler portavoz en américa
latina' de la agencia de la onu para los
refugiados tenemos situaciones que
llevan años décadas e incluso en donde
generaciones de refugiados continúan sin
poder volver a sus países y es por eso
que no solamente la respuesta
humanitaria que es esencial para salvar
vidas pero también una voluntad política
de encontrar una solución de acabar con
los conflictos de promover el diálogo de
de evitar que hayan estas persecuciones
estas violaciones a los derechos humanos
son esenciales si queremos realmente
resolver esta situación spindler también
advirtió que la situación en
latinoamérica es igual de alarmante que
la que se vive en etiopía burkina faso
mianmar nigeria afganistán y la
república democrática del congo también
en nuestra región vemos esta situación
de desarraigo de la
desplazamiento del éxodo de millones de
personas que tienen que dejar sus
hogares ya sea para desplazarse dentro
de sus países o hacia otros países la
situación en nuestra región es también
muy es preocupante el 20 de mayo el
acnur pidió a varios países levantar las
restricciones contra el covent 19 en las
que muchos se han aferrado para negar
asilo a las personas que huyen de los
conflictos este organismo señala que
contravienen un derecho fundamental